the one way to explore
the the galaxy is by just sitting here
on earth and waiting
so if we can just get really good at
waiting it's like a more more or these
interstellar objects that fly in
you can just wait for them to come to
you same with the aliens you can wait
for them to come to you
if you get really good at waiting then
that's one way to do the exploration
because eventually the thing will come
to you maybe that's the entire maybe
the intelligent alien civilizations
get much better at waiting and so they
all decide
so game theoretically to start waiting
and it's just a bunch of
like ancient intelligent civilizations
of aliens
all throughout the universe they're just
sitting there waiting for each other
look you can't just be good at waiting
you got to know how to chill
okay like like you can't just like sit
around and do nothing you got to be
you get you got to know how to chill i
honestly think that
as we progress if the aliens are
anything like us
we enjoy loving things we do
and it it's uh it's very possible that
we just figure out mechanisms
here on earth to enjoy our life and we
just stay here on our for uh
forever that exploration becomes less
and less of an interesting thing to do
and so you basically yes wait and chill
you get really optimally good at
chilling and thereby
exploring is not that uh interesting so
you know in terms of 4 000 years would
be nothing for scientists we'll be
chilling and just
all kinds of scientific explorations
will become
possible because we'll just be here so
chill
so chill
you